Leon: Syria, everybody is concerned about
Syria.
Again, every time Russia does something, every
time they bring more troops, every time they
establish yet another base, this time a stone's
throw from Turkish border, a NATO member,
the official Washington is surprised.
Surprised, surprised, surprised.
What's the endgame there in Syria?
Vladimir: Well, I think as with all of the
foreign policy adventures of this current
regime, the origins are domestic and are found
inside.
And once Eastern Ukraine, the Donbass became
a quagmire for the regime, once Ukraine proved
a too difficult target, and the so-called
Novorossiya Project clearly failed, the Kremlin's
propaganda machine needed new ammunition,
a new fodder to maintain, to revive rather,
the fate of the strongman image, to show another
round of television pictures purporting to
be a great power, to be sending troops halfway
across the world in an instant, to be an equal
in the world stage, if you will.
And this is when Syria came in.
And if you look at the Kremlin-controlled
television channels in Russia, which is of
course all the major television channels in
Russia today, you will see that Syria has
replaced Ukraine as the main subject.
Whereas before, they used to show all the
time the Donbass and the fight against the
so-called fascists and Banderavites in the
Donbass, now they're sharing Syria and the
so-called fight against terrorism that Putin
is, therefore, conducting in Syria.
Others, of course, in additional very important
reason, I think that the Kremlin is doing
this, the informal club of dictators is a
pretty loyal one, and Mr. Putin doesn't like
to see a fellow despot fall from power.
He's already seen too many in his time, from
Gaddafi to Yanukovych.
And I think an additional goal in this is
to help preserve Bashar al-Assad in power
in Syria and, of course, it's evident now
to everybody that the chief targets of the
Russian Air Force in Syria are not in fact
ISIS strongholds, but are the anti-Assad opposition
forces.